people have me on they expect me to to
make the case for essential workers and
of course I do
because everybody understands that case
now when dirty jobs went on nobody was
making that case so I felt special
and I felt like you know iconoclast out
there saying hey don't forget about this
one in this one this one right now while
I still hold them in the absolute
highest esteem I'm amazed at how we've
taken 35 million people and beamed them
on essential that to me is something I
reckon we're gonna look back on with
great linguistic embarrassment the main
question that I think I wanted to ask
you that I think will sort of frame
everything else we're gonna talk about
is that there seems to be a narrative
out there from a certain set of people
that it's like Oh going back to work
it's just too risky and no one really
wants to work anyway and you know aoc
had some version of this sort of thing
like only in America would we value work
so high and as a guy that I have seen do
the craziest jobs you know where you're
stepping in [ __ ] your hands in this
animal the bats electricity water you
can give me ten other examples of the
crazy things that you've had people do
you work with people who would do this
for a living can you just talk about
just broadly like the importance of work
relative to finding purpose in life
relative to just setting up the rest of
the things that you want out of life
because that actually is one of the
things that I'm most worried about right
now that as we sort of give away our
day-to-day lives that we're gonna forget
that work is important not I'm not
talking about slavery but I'm just
talking about the getting up with
something to do because it makes you
some money so you can do everything else
with your life that you want to do so
it's the frog in the boiling water I
share your fear it's not gonna happen
like a light switch though
what's the old poem not not with a bang
but a whimper and the way it'll happen
here is people like AOC and others who
genuinely or maybe not so genuinely
believe that work is fundamentally
another expression for drudgery are
going to make those points they're going
they're going to reduce it to something
that's purely transactional that's
that's the first step and if you only
look at what you do as a means to make
money then I then then then you're not
an interesting person okay
it's just yes it's such a
one-dimensional way to look at something
that should in my view and oftentimes
does define us you know it's our work
it's it's it's the thing we choose to do
with the most conscious chunk of our
life and so to reduce it to a paycheck
is dumb obviously there's a giant
transactional element involved in it but
there's so much more dirty jobs happened
because because I couldn't follow in my
grandfather's footsteps which I very
much wanted to do my pop was a guy who
could build a house without a blueprint
he only went to the seventh grade but he
had the the chip right in his brain that
he could take your watch apart and put
it back together blindfolded he could he
could build a house he could run pipe he
he was a master electrician steam fitter
pipe fitter mechanic architect all of
that well he was heroic in his youth in
time for those things today he'd be a
mr. Sullivan you know he's transparent
and so many of those trades so many of
those those vocations have fallen into
into this gap between blue and white
collar they've they've lost their luster
and we're simply not properly gobsmacked
the way we used to be about the miracle
of modern plumbing or the miracle that
happens when you flick the switch and
the light comes on so so dirty jobs was
meant to be a tribute to my grandfather
initially and it was and then it became
a rumination on essential work which is
interesting right because obviously the
headlines have have have caught up with
that and that's really been my great
good fortune over the years I do average
shows with low production value but big
beams and I stick with those themes and
every couple of years the headlines will
catch up with them dirty jobs and the
people we featured became weirdly
relevant when the economy crashed in
2009 and it's become weirdly relevant
this month I've been on every talk show
there is to talk about essential work
and it's funny I'll tell you what
happens I mean look there's a there's a
poster I keep it on my wall to remind me
I put a pig on a pedestal many years ago
for a lot of reasons and people have me
on they expect me to to make the case
for essential workers and of course I do
because everybody understands that case
now when dirty jobs went on nobody was
making that case so I felt special and I
felt like you know iconoclast out there
saying hey don't forget about this one
and this one this one right now
while I still hold them in the absolute
highest esteem I'm amazed at how we've
taken 35 million people and beamed them
on essential that to me is something I
reckon we're gonna look back on with
great linguistic embarrassment because
that bet that's exactly what I wanted to
ask you next so God continue continue no
it's you're different that I just
realized what that was that was the
question really like when once we say to
35 million people you're not essential
it's not just about the job that they do
it's it's the message that's getting
across to their lives which in some ways
I actually think in some ways if they
can get through it and then rethink what
they do maybe there is something else
they want to do but I don't think that's
the message that most people are gonna
get I think we're gonna leave people
with some sort of existential crisis
we're doing it it's part of the grieving
process I was saying earlier people are
coming to terms with the fact that their
vocations don't matter in the eyes of
virtually everyone who has a show to
host because in our in our well intended
enthusiasm to celebrate the essential
workers we've done a thing we always do
with the language and I am I am NOT a
politically correct person I'd at least
I try not to be but language does matter
a lot and you know in my own foundation
when I feel most comfortably in my own
lane I talk about education and the
skilled trades and higher education is a
turn of phrase that has become
inculcated and when we talk about the
importance of higher education well who
would doubt it of course we need big
people with big brains doing important
work but what what does higher education
imply if not the existence of many forms
of lower education subordinate education
so the language bakes in a terrible kind
of analysis if you don't get a four-year
degree if you don't buy into the idea
that the most expensive path
is the best path for the most people
then you wind up doing something they
don't call it lower education because
that would just be crazy but they call
it alternative huh we have some
alternatives for you Dave maybe you'd
like it over here in a trade school or
perhaps you'd be comfortable over here
in a community college or in a
fellowship or an apprenticeship so we
did that in education and the unintended
consequences are breathtaking we're
doing it now with the very heart of
people's identities and we're doing it
around the simple word we're not meaning
to do it but you watch it's it's gonna
come back over the net with a lot of
topspin people are already pissed off
about it I just don't think they quite
understand why yeah let's actually back
up for a second and talk about your
foundation a little bit because
everything you're saying right now I
think does get to a trend that I've been
seeing for a while which is I've had so
many guests who come from academia and
you know so much of our national
conversation is about outrage culture
and canceled culture and what's
happening at college is and now because
of YouTube's average people and I mean
that in the best sense of average all of
us can can watch incredible thinkers
give lectures you can watch Jordan
Peterson lectures on YouTube for free
and maybe get more information from that
then you can from a semester that you're
paying 25 grand for so talk about your
foundation and and sort of can you just
relate that a little bit to what you see
happening with higher ed relative to if
you have a trade right now it's like you
are essential again in the best sense of
essential that's not I'm not putting
down the non-essential maybe we can come
up with a better word for it right now
well we should because everything has a
season and part of the reason we're
locked in this endless feedback loop of
nonsense is because we're in love with
cookie cutter advice and so we dispense
it with certainty and this is what
politicians do to be elected they have
to they they have to say the thing
that's going to resonate with the most
people and so they wind up
they wind up retrenching two bromines
and platitudes and tropes that's what
safety first is if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles instead of non-stop
yelling check out our lifestyle playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell